I can smell the vinegar. Ooh, cool!
Color changes like this always amaze,
and this activity
lets children begin to see why they
are important and useful in science.
Today we're going to be doing a bit of
an experiment with this.
Do you know what this is? Brain!
Could be a brain, what do you think?
Cabbage? It's a red cabbage (even though it's not really red).
So, what we're going to do:
I'm going to chop a bit off.
It's getting blue. Why is it going blue?
Because the cabbage colour...
So you think the cabbage colour is coming out of the cabbage and going into the water?
Yeah! You can do some really fun things with this coloured water,
but we need to make loads more.
This kind of cabbage is red because it contains chemicals called
anthocyanins.
Blitzing the cabbage in water
lets us extract those chemicals and use
them for our experiments.
Right, we're going to do some science now with this. I'm gonna get some vinegar,
and pour it in there. What do you think might happen?
Change a little bit of colour?
Explode? Maybe it will explode...
Look carefully while I pour this. Look what happens.
I think it is going to change colour.
Cool! So this cabbage water changes colour
in a slightly strange way, so shall we see if it changes colour with other things?
Yeah! This is actually bicarbonate of soda.
What do you think might happen this time?
Hmm... it's going to go all fizzy?
Me too, I think it's going to go fizzy.
Watch carefully what happens again.
I knew it was gonna turn blue! No you didn't.
Let's try some fizzy water, yeah?
What colour, guys, do you think this is
going to be go this time?
A different colour completely?
Yes, because it's a different thing.
What's going on? It's going pink!
Is the water more like vinegar or bicarbonate of soda?
More like the vinegar.
Yeah so there's something in common in the fizzy water and the vinegar.
It's fun to just look at all the
color changes you can get with this
cabbage juice, but this activity is a great
way to introduce children to the idea
we can learn about the properties of
substances using these chemical reactions.
We call liquids like this cabbage juice
indicator solutions because they tell us
something about the chemical composition
of other substances.
In this case liquids which turn the juice red
have properties that scientists categorise
as acidic.
Liquids that make it go blue or green are know as alkaline.
Download the info sheet to find
out more about this experiment.
We'd love to see photos of whatever you get up to
and subscribe to see lots of other great experiments.